hello everyone story about no videos for
the past few days but I decided to take
a little break after that adjustable
masters 2020 and also I was in a
hospital but it's not nothing serious
just having some checkups done but if
you guys are interested I'm gonna
mention something at the end of the
video but this this is game 17 from the
TCC Superfinal season 18 a lot of you
guys requested to show at least a few
games so that's what we're gonna do so
this is game 17 one of the nicer ones
let's dive straight into it so as usual
they are using their prearranged moves
to see how the the engines will handle
it in you know tricky situations and
this game is no different so Leela with
the white pieces opens with efore sorry
about that
we've c5 by stockfish and Knight to f3
so neither 3 we have D 6 and now d4 see
characters Knight captures and 90 to f6
we have Knight to c3 and of course a6
the knight of Sicilian is on the board
and here well you can play a lot of
things we have Bishop to g5 so e 6 + f4
this is the the the standard mainline
with Bishop e7 and Queen to f3 Queen the
c7 and a queen-sized Castle now we have
nightly to d7 so these are all the the
top moves that are played even in
Grandmaster games we have g4 preparing
to capture and well extend upon all the
way to g5 and black of course will start
his expansion on the Queen side so a
stock view goes for b5 we have captures
captures and now g5 pushing the knight
back we have 90 d7 and now pushing even
further with f5 and it's a it's a very
interesting idea first off you're
offering this pawn here so black can
even capture it with the chair but
you're just gonna play King to b1 and
next black still has to deal with all of
these threats you can even use rook to
g1 with tempo as the bishop will be
hanging on g5 so it's not not the
greatest of options so here we have 9th
to c5 and now comes f6
so busting open blacks King side we have
G characters on f6 bush G captures on f6
and out
faith and here there are a lot of moves
that can be played here but here we have
worked the g1 and this is the last book
move so it is as of this position that
Lila and stockfish are now playing on
their own so here we have h5 not
allowing IDs like Queen to h5 as there
would be a lot of pressure here I'd be
six point is weak and black wants to
develop the bishop over to be 7 so h5
and now a3 and here there are moves have
been placed here like Bishop e7 rook to
b8 but the Moustakas plays Queen to b6
is actually a new move in the position
so already as of move 17 we have a
completely new game so Lila continues
with a nice prophylactic King to be one
why not black still has a dark square
bishop so it does make sense and
stockfish starts the attack with b4 and
okay eight characters on b4 Queen
captures and now the wonderful rook to
g7 and this is why why I said that this
game is like the the second brave
stroking chess history as we all know
which rook is the first brave a stroke
in chess history if you haven't seen it
I will put a link to that game in a
description it's a very old game in the
very old video I I will have to do a
remake of that video in 60 frames per
second at some point but but do check it
out if you have and it's it's just a
masterpiece for your friends at the bar
in the library nobody out here
Lila offers the rook and it's very
interesting what happens if the rook is
accepted because after Bishop characters
pawn captures this rook is under attack
and after you defend this now comes
Knight to f5 simply defending
threatening Knight b6 check and once
this Knight is captured then it's nice
the d5 attacking the Queen and also
preparing Knight to f6 check and here
it's really crazy let's say Queen e5
Knight f6 check King moves you're gonna
capture the rook here and now again it's
very dangerous if you move the knight g8
Queen just wins the game on the spot so
black has to sort of develop the Queen's
I move the King so the rook guards this
square but it doesn't help all that much
Queen can capture on f5 Bishop captures
here and now Queen a for going after the
d6 pawn and that's pretty much it the
King can move but still night of sex
you're gonna play g8 on the next move
and it's just game over so here after
work the g7 of course towfish
doesn't accept that he was a rogue b8
and here threatening
Matan unbe - so Lila has to defend you
could defend with b3 but that's no way
to play in great style so Lila goes for
Bishop to b5 with check now offers a the
the bishop before or for closing the B
file but here just 96 attacks the Queen
and the rook this is just better for
white
so instead Stockbridge decides for rook
captures on b5 we have Knight 2d
characters on b5 and a captors on b5 and
only now d5 again offering the rook but
now with e5 Lila cleared the way for the
Queen for Queen to c6 check and again
it's super crazy if the rook is captured
because you just get captures rook g8
and now again Queen to c6 check and
there is no good reply here if there
should be seven Queen eight check just
wins the rook you're gonna block King g7
Queen captures here and it looks
dangerous for white but it's really not
there is no way for for black to
continue and the black will just get to
checkmate it here so instead after E 5
stockfish says I'm not interested in
that rook and yes it is a very brave
rook
so just before b7 first takes takes a
away the c6 squared from the Queen we
have Queen to e3 now and again
Levi offers the rook so what can happen
well it's interesting now if Bishop
characters have characters in Ruby g8
now there's the very interesting rook to
d4 idea and that's the stuff Queen a5
and B 4 just wins back material after
the Queen moves you can cat capture this
guy here and now it's well now or never
you either get rid of this pawn or not
but you if you capture it now see
captures on d6 gives white a beautiful
pass the d6 pawn and also the g1 square
is a defendant so there's no there's no
check for for black here and the white
will again be better so stockfish again
not interested in the rook goes Queen to
c4 now if route before you can go Queen
to f1 check you can you can move your
pieces and also you clear the be for
square for the pawn so here Lila goes he
captures on d6 again the the the rook is
offered but you know you kind of don't
want to play it again because now this
point guards this square and if you get
the dis than Queen g5 just there is no
defense against this checkmate it is
just game over well whatever black does
it's it's just over like you can play f6
but I mean that's only only prolonging
the inevitable so after each capture
sandy 6 we have Knight to d7
now blocking the past pawn but also
going after the f6 pawn here and now we
have Queen to a7 again offering the rook
but now it's a rook for two pieces so
not really all that impressive
so here Queen to c6 defending and only
now that stock is defended everything
properly only now does Lila move the
rogue back so look the g5 and it's very
important as it attacks the b5 point so
here we have Queen to a6 stockfish
forces a queen trade will not force this
basically offers and Lila declines just
guarding this pawn guarding this point
in nicely centralizing the Queen so rush
up the c6 and now Queen to d3 with a
third attacker going after the bb5 pawn
and of course if you push it the Queen
just hangs so here we have Knight back
to b6
but now feel free to pause the video and
find the absolute best move for Lila
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
on clearing the B file for your pieces
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's d7 width check first open up the D
file and then go after the b5 point and
that's exactly what happens here with
Knight captures back on b7 and only now
Knight captures on b5 so now you're
threatening 97 check with a nice fork of
course you have to do something about
that King d8 displayed but it's not all
the great just h4 Lila says I'm in
complete control here I'm just gonna
improve my position before doing
anything else
so here we have Queen to b7 but now
Knight to d6 with a nice double attack
here so of course dogfish gets rid of
the knight we have captures captures and
now King the c8 unpinning so the knife
can finally move but now rook the d3
preparing to bring the rook here for for
the for the final attack but now Queen
c7 offering a queen trade Lila again
declines Queen a3 and now II five just
are starting to push the passed pawn but
now Queen to e7 again just hoping
to get rid of this pond so so df1 now
becomes a passed pawn we have Knight b6
now offering a queen trade and here rook
captures on e5 and now Lila finally
trades Queens but now it's this position
where Lila has two rooks against the
rook Bishop and night and usually the
bishop and Knight are much stronger but
here Lila also has two two extra points
and two of those extra points are
connected passed pawns so it's not going
to be easy for starfish and sorry the
rogue didn't capture the pawn captured
III I thought the rogue capture but yeah
it's actually three passed pawns and
it's not going to be easy
so Bishop to d7 but now rook to d6 and
now this is a very very technical end
game which of course both Lila and
starfish would convert but I was I was
more interested in what happened prior
to the endgame but we are going to show
it just the same so here our King to c7
pushing the rogue back we have looked at
f6 going after the pawn and now rook to
e8 so there's nothing you can do to
defend the pawn you could try something
like Bishop here but that's just not
very good you're just gonna capture the
bishop and let's say after rook he
captures and e6f character is just a
rook to f8 and you are either queening
or winning material so nothing nothing
about this move is is helpful for black
castle rook to e8 instead but now rook
captures on f7 so grabbing yet another
pawn now it's four points to one Knight
to c8 and now even a rook captures an H
5 so 4 points to 0 of course this is
this is a very nice we have Knight
captures on e7 grabbing at least one
point and now b3 now leo has to activate
the king and the Queen side pawns
so King D 6 we have rook to f2 now
bringing the rug back and now Knight to
c6
we have rook tadi to with check King to
c7 and now rook to h7 now preparing the
BH file for the pawn we have Knight to
e5 in just h5 now we have King to c6 and
h6 so that is not a very impressive pass
pawn bishop to f5 are pushing the rogue
back and rook the g7 preparing h7 so
look to h8 not allowing it but now rook
to F do now
ok you can no longer guard the dh1
successfully but now you
after stockfish species so rook to f2 we
measure up to h7 and now king b2 just
starting to improve the position we have
king b5 black does the same and now rook
to f6 nicely defending the pawn and
cutting the king off from from the 6th
rank bishop the e4 now again opening up
an attack towards the pond but now rook
the b7 still keeping an eye on the b7
square Knight to f3 and now rook back to
e so and so here with rook to e7 lily is
actually threatening rook to f4 with a
double attack on the bishop and you will
not have any squares for it as the King
is blocking it so you either have to
move it but then you lose the night or
you remain here and then you lose the
bishop so here stockfish played Knight
to g5 but it's not much better we have
worked a 6 preparing rook to a5 check to
pick up the night here and now Bishop to
f3 but there there isn't much to be done
here we have worked a 5 with check King
to d6 attacking the rook and now of
course you cannot capture the night
because the rook hang so first looked at
e3 and now this is a tag this is
attacked and there's not much you can do
even if you go for this rook to g8 to
defend the night you can just remove the
defender of the bishop and the the
resulting endgame would still be winning
I mean it's three points to zero so
after rook III we have rook captures and
h6 but now it was also in this position
that stockfish resigned the game or
rather auction will agree the the
advantage is just too too big to
continue this game which is when
resignation happens in in their matches
so a brilliant victory balilla full of
sacrifice is full of nicely blocked
paths full of everything but in the end
it is stop fish that won the super final
so the era of old-school engines is not
over this time stock fish prevailed and
won the super final out of 100 100 games
the result was fifty three and a half at
forty six and a half in stalkers favor
so Leela season season 19 can be all
yours but this one was all stock fish
and there were some other interesting
games if you guys have your favorite do
you have to use hashtag suggestion and I
will check it out now regarding
why why I was in the hospital I was I
was getting an exam I had like had a
choreography in some other exam I don't
know what's it called but basically I
will have to get some heart surgery
I don't know when probably in the next
six months but it's nothing new I had
this condition since birth I was born
with a defective heart valve and well
I'm just gonna get a new one an
artificial one and that was basically
going to be it it shouldn't be showing
me all that much of a much of a hassle
but we'll see how it goes I will keep
you guys informed but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Aaron Lennon
Simonis plunge in in India Marco Polo
domsky and Ricardo Montalvo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos Aaron
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of DTCC super
final checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day